If our support vector machine learns the class x square plus y square.
Let's call this new feature over here z.
So, we know that z equals x square plus y square.
And we're trying to learn a hyperplane between x, y and z.
z is always nonnegative because of the distance to the origin.
And magically, for all the red points, the distance to the origin is small.
And for all the blue circles, distance to the origin is large.
So we show the exact same data in this new projection of x and z, omitting y.
I find that all the Xs have a small value of z.
Whereas all the circles have a larger value of z.
And just to understand this.
To really get this.
z measures the distance to the origin.
So here's a small z, here's a small z, here's a small z, here's a small z.
And for the blue circles, the distance is large, as you can see over here.
So if I remap the data into this new coordinate system with the z,
you find all the blue circles have a large value for
z and all the red Xs have a small value for z.